Officially the Apollo 10 mission of 1969 was
a dress rehearsal for the more famous Apollo
11- designed to test all of procedures and
equipment needed to land on the Moon save
for the actual act of the landing itself.
(To assure it was just a practice run, they
did not put enough fuel in the LM to land
and leave the Moon.
They felt that if they did, Thomas Stafford
and Eugene Cernan might just decide to go
for it.
Interestingly, Cernan and Stafford almost
were the first to land on the Moon anyway,
as the crew mistakenly put duplicate commands
into the flight computer and, upon the ascent
engine ignition, the LM started spinning nearly
out of control because of it.
They only regained control of the craft a
few revolutions away from the situation being
unrecoverable, which ultimately would have
seen them crashing onto the Moon.)
While many of the mission’s details have
been overshadowed by the later Apollo 11 mission,
one in particular still stands out- that time
a couple pieces of fecal matter free-floated
around the command module for several minutes.
This scatological tidbit from the history
of space exploration occurred on the sixth
day of the Apollo 10 mission as they were
orbiting the Moon.
As recorded in official NASA transcripts of
the mission, the first incident was initially
noticed by Commander Tom Stafford.
The other two aboard were John Young and the
aforementioned Eugene Cernan, both of whom
would later walk on the surface of the Moon
as part of the Apollo 16 and 17 missions respectively.
(While Commander Stafford never walked on
the Moon, he is the joint record holder for
the highest speed ever attained by man, relative
to Earth, when the Apollo 10 craft reached
24,791 miles per hour.)
As noted, Commander Stafford noticed the floating
feces first, alerting his crewmates to its
presence by exclaiming “Oh” quickly followed
by a bemused, “Who did it?”
According to the official transcripts of the
mission, the next crew member to notice the
flying, fibre-rich projectile was Young, who
let out a “Where did that come from?”
as the fecal matter floated slowly into his
eye-line.
Cernan apparently didn’t notice the poop
until it was explicitly identified by Stafford
who alerted both him and ground control to
its existence by saying quite matter of factly:
Give me a napkin quick.
There’s a turd floating through the air!
The transcript further went on to reveal that
Stafford and the rest of the crew were stifling
laughter throughout this exchange, with several
portions of said transcript detailing that
the turd invasion was punctuated by fits of
laughter and giggling unable to be credited
to a singular member of the crew.
After some playful banter, Cernan heroically,
and with no regard for his personal safety,
decided to dispose of the so-named turd with
a nearby plastic bag.
Shortly after normal mission tasks resumed,
the trio were interrupted by a second bit
of fecal matter floating listlessly through
the air, prompting yet another sweeping round
of denial from each astronaut, with Stafford
insisting that his poop was stickier than
the one currently enjoying its interstellar
freedom.
Young likewise asserted that his poop “hit
that bag”.
The “bag” in this context referred to
the decidedly low-tech way astronauts had
to deal with feces back then and the reason
why said astronauts seemed to know in detail
how “sticky” their rear expulsions were.
Fecal Collection Bag
As we’ve talked about before, (see: How
do Astronauts Go to Bathroom in Space), doing
one’s necessaries in space has been an issue
almost since the dawn of space travel.
For instance, on the morning of May 5, 1961,
astronaut Alan Shepard, the second man / first
American in space, was forced to sit through
several hours of delays on what was otherwise
supposed to be a very brief mission.
He ultimately remarked, “Man, I gotta pee.”
With no good options available, he was at
first implored to “hold it”.
Eventually things became critical and it was
decided that Shepard should pee in his spacesuit
after its electronics were temporarily deactivated
with the hope that his peeing in the suit
wouldn’t short out his bio-sensors and give
him a jolt in the process.
The hack was mostly successful in that he
didn’t electrocute himself and he no longer
had to pee, but it did ultimately short the
sensors.
Soon after, Shepard became the first American
in space… soaking in his own urine.
Today, most astronaut waste is handled by
a remarkably sophisticated space-toilet that
simply vacuums things up.
Back in the late 1960s though, astronauts
didn’t have this luxury and had to poop
into what basically amounted to a plastic
bag taped to their butts.
The exact procedure for pooping in space at
the time, as outlined in the Apollo Experience
Report – Crew Provisions and Equipment Subsystem
published by NASA in March of 1972, was as
follows:
To use the FCA (Fecal-Collection Assembly),
the crewman attaches the outer fecal bag properly
and proceeds with fecal elimination.
Upon completion of the action and subsequent
sanitary cleansing, the tissues and refuse
are placed in the inner fecal/emesis bag.
The crewman then removes the germicide pouch,
cuts the outer protective seal, and places
it in the inner bag.
Finally, all items are placed into the outer
fecal bag, the bag is sealed, the germicide
pouch is ruptured by hand pressure, the bag
is kneaded, and the contents are stowed in
the waste-stowage compartment….
Nothing has proved more effective than the
current system, which has proved adequate
for all flights, although the crewmen have
expressed dislike for it.
If you’re wondering, the germicide pouch
was there to kill off as many microbes as
possible to reduce the likelihood of microbial
produced gases swelling the bag to the point
of bursting.
However, NASA wasn’t content to assume no
bags would turn into fecal grenades, so they
planned for that contingency as well, as noted
in the report:
If any fecal bags were to rupture during the
mission, the waste-stowage compartment could
emit fecal odors.
Therefore, a bladder and an overboard vent
system have been placed in the compartment.
The system contains a 215-micron filter, a
check-relief valve, and a vent valve to the
urine overboard dump line.
During boost, the waste-stowage vent valve
is opened to purge nitrogen wastes from the
crew compartment.
A check valve vents into the crew compartment
at differential pressure of 2 psi.
After the vent valve has been closed during
a mission, the check valve vents if ruptured
fecal bags create a pressure of 2 psi.
Then the crewman, alerted by the fecal odor,
can position the waste-stowage valve to vent
the odor overboard at periodic intervals.
Not perhaps planning enough for human error,
by some unknown means some of the poop escaped
its plastic prison during Apollo 10, leaving
it free to wander around the command module,
boldly going where no turd had gone before.
So who let free the smelly projectiles?
Despite extensive research into the matter
FOR SCIENCE, unfortunately who the poop belonged
to cannot be conclusively established.
All three members of the crew at one point
or another denied that the fecal matter in
question was theirs during the immediate aftermath,
with the most adamant among them being Stafford,
who, as mentioned, deflected accusations away
from himself by claiming that his expulsions
were “more sticky” than the ones currently
invading their space- a bold but otherwise
fine tactic in the Who Smelt It, Dealt It
game.
That said, in an effort to leave no stone
unturned to find out who the culprit was,
we read through the 171 pages of NASA’s
transcript of day six of the Apollo 10 mission
and found a few clues.
We know that earlier that same day Cernan
and Stafford talked about going to the bathroom,
but Young did not, at least as far as we can
find.
However, during the second turd incident,
Young did note in response to one of Stafford’s
assertions that “Mine was stickier than
that…”, “Mine was too.
It hit the bag…”
So we can deduce from this that Young did
indeed recently defecate, but likewise asserted
that his stuck to the bag.
If we are to believe both Young and Stafford
in this, it would seem to rule them out.
A little more evidence in the finger pointing
at Cernan is that he noted after going to
the bathroom that he couldn’t smell a thing,
suggesting that he’d just gone the big #2
and, at least as far as the transcript reveals,
was the last person to poop before Turdgate
and Turdgate 2: The Reckoning.
(Of course, when exactly Young went to the
bathroom is undocumented, so Young going last
can’t be wholly ruled out.)
The fact that Cernan’s expulsions weren’t
smelly also is a small strike against him,
with presumably more stinky fecal bits escaping
the bag being more immediately noticeable
than the springtime fresh variety.
It’s also noted that during the second incident,
while Cernan did state, “Here’s another
godd*&m turd.
What’s the matter with you guys?”
implying he thought one of the other two was
to blame, both of the others subsequently
pointed out the sticky nature of their defecations.
In response to this, Cernan then backtracked
a little, stating, “I don’t know whose
that is.
I can neither claim it nor disclaim it.”
He then laughed.
Unfortunately the transcript does not give
adequate detail of the laugh.
Was it perhaps a nervous chuckle, with him
knowing deep down he was guilty?
Or was it a general guffaw at the absurdity
of it all- three humans floating around over
two hundred thousand miles from Earth in one
of the most expensive and advanced pieces
of engineering ever constructed, orbiting
the Moon while their own fecal matter more
or less orbited them.
Further research into the solid rear emissions
of the trio, such as the Apollo mission fecal
sample mass measurements, were unhelpful in
potentially identifying the culprit.
While none of this provides definitive proof
by any means, based on the scant evidence
we have to go on, it would seem Cernan is
the most likely source of the offending fecal
matter.
Of course, Stafford was the discoverer of
the first turd and we can only wonder whether
the “first smeller is the feller” rule
extends to such circumstances as visually
spotting solid waste in space.
He also was the first, and most adamant, to
deny it could have been him.
Doth protest too much?
On the other hand, Young’s fecal emissions
were decidedly absent from the transcript
logs that fateful day.
Was there tampering to protect one of NASA’s
most accomplished astronauts?
If nothing else, we hope you agree that this
qualifies as a “fun fact” you can use
to inject yourself into conversation circles
at cocktail parties in order to avoid having
to be that person who awkwardly hovers just
outside of said circles.
Arming oneself to avoid such a circumstance
is half the point of Today I Found Out, after
all.
If you thought the Apollo mission fecal matter
containment system was a marvel of engineering,
you might be interested to know that the LM
urine collection system for various reasons
had to be pressurized.
To ensure that the astronauts weren’t…
injured while urinating, it was noted in the
aforementioned Apollo Experience Report that
“a prime urine-transfer design constraint
for the LM was that the crewmen would be protected
at all times from pressure differentials…”
This system, however, was a little buggy at
first (though there were never any reported
injuries).
NASA engineers being NASA engineers, they
worked it out in the end.
The oldest surviving large, single deposit
(not found mixed with others and not broken
up) piece of human poop is approximately 1,000
years old, expelled by a Viking.
This seven inch long piece of fecal matter
is currently on display at the the York Archaeological
Resource Centre.
You can read more about this here: A Historic
Defecation: The Curious Case of the Lloyds
Bank Turd
In zero gravity, human’s naturally poop
more, to help combat this in the days of the
Apollo missions, NASA fed astronauts an ultra-low
fibre diet prior to missions to minimise the
amount of pooping they would do.